Jean-Michel coagard directeur académique
des services de l'éducation nationale
anciennement inspecteur d'académie il va
falloir s'y faire le titre à changé mais
les missions ont changé aussi non non
elles n'ont pas changé ça marque
simplement l'idée que nous sommes
maintenant plus proches des fonctions
stratégiques qui s'exercent au niveau de
la région au niveau de l'Académie près
du recteur que vous avez reçu récemment
en tout cas bienvenue à vous bonsoir
bienvenue sur ce plateau du 78
Jean-Philippe met député PS et resté
également on va parler éducation de
cette rentrée comment s'est passé votre
rentrée plutôt bien il y a tout même un
incident si on peut qualifier comme ça
notable la la séquestration d'une
inspectrice dans une école d'cher par
des parents oui globalement c'est pour
moi très bien passéir de se fait isoler
se fait isoler bon c'est mal encontreux
ça arrive dans d'autres contrés parfois
là c'est un peu regrettable il me semble
parce que on connaît bien les règles
dans le département et c'est peut-être
pas utile de se mobiliser à ce point
même si on comprend le regard des des
parents attentifs à leurs enfants on a
vu il y a quelques instants les les
images on vous a entendu lors de la
conférence de presse que vous de rentrée
que vous avez tenu vous avez mentionné
ces 22 nouveaux enseignants qui ont été
accueillis dans les ivelines mais vous
avez tout de même parlé du fait qu'il
était difficile de les garder c'était
une crainte aussi les enseignants qui
viennent dans le département quitent le
département assez souvent mais nous
sommes une académie formatrice un
département
formateur at tire des jeunes d'abord ça
attire des jeunes à l'université avant
mais vient un moment après qu'ils aient
pris leur fonction quelques années où
ils font de leur vie de famille ils
veulent s'installer une partie d'entre
eux venant d'ailleurs se dit
légitimement ben rentrons chez nous donc
il cherche à repartir il faut juste
prendre conscience de ce turnover et
savoir le gérer et amplifier peut-être
le les mouvement d'enseignants de jeunes
qui arrivent et donc ouvrir encore plus
de place au concours mais je crois que
ce sera le casalisant pour la la
continuité des projets pour la
périisation des projets qui sont menés
non non il faut il faut il faut rester
réaliste dans ce département pour le
premier decret il y a 7500 postees 8500
enseignants bon les nombres dont nous
parlons c'est 3 à 400 enseignants par an
qui demandent à partir la question est
leur renouvellement donc dans une
période où on aura davantage d'accès au
concours
peut-être les jeunes auront plus
confiance dans l'ouverture qu'on leur
fait via leurs études universitaires on
peut espérer que le problème sera régulé
effectivement la entrée s'est bien passé
le recteur qui était sur ce plateau en
début de semaine nous a tenu les mêmes
propos il a tout de même parlé d'une
rentrée de transition puisqu'il y a un
changement de gouvernement le temps que
les mesure se mettent en place on était
plutôt dans une rentrée la dernière de
sous la de l'air Châtel on va dire du
précédent min ministre est-ce que la la
rentrée payon justement a du mal à
prendre et en tout cas il y a des
attentes les parents sont dans l'attente
aussi de arrivée de professeur de
réforme de l'éducation juste deux points
peut-être il y a une question de climat
d'abord du point de vue du climat nous
savons réussir les rentré et comme il y
a une forme de
d'attente le climat est plutôt à la
confiance les enseignants attendent mais
sont sont confiants me semble-t-il les
parents aussi ils attendent maintenant
la rentrée suivante nous sommes bien
placés dans les ielines sans doute pour
les grands thèmes qui se dégage déjà de
de la concertation sur la refondation
qui doit déboucher sur un projet de loi
d'ici la fin de l'année on pense que la
réflexion notamment territorial est déjà
avancé dans certains secteurs des
divvines et que nous serons sans trop de
difficulté nous mettre dans les pas de
des orientations qui sert prises t
peut-être sur les rythmes de Scola même
si c'est compliqué mais par exemple
aussi sur l'équipement numérique des
écoles et des collègesù nous sommes en
avance même chose vous l'avez vu avec la
venue du président de la République sur
des questions comme semain la cohérence
des parcours des élèves de la maternelle
jusqu'à la 3e voilà quelques focales qui
sont
d'actualité vers lesqueles on devrait
avoir des orientations renouvelé et pour
lesquels nous sommes prêts alors il y a
plusieurs dossiers justement qui vont
être abordés j'aimerais votre réaction
sur la question de des décours de de
morale la morale laïque alors ça fait
même pas l'unanimité au sein du Parti
socialiste récemment c'est le maire de
Paris qui qui a dit que le terme était
pas forcément très très bien choisi vous
en pensez quoi de ces cours de moral
laïque dès le plus jeune âge la première
chose ce n'est pas de penser euh de
donner une opinion c'est de de
simplement constater que quel que soit
le libélé de cette thématique
historiquement elle a périodiquement été
rediscuté et comme on l'a noté dans les
journaux ces jourci il y a pas tellement
longtemps donc c'est une interrogation
euh à mon avis hein qui parcourt la
totalité de la question de l'école dans
la République on peut pas ne pas se la
poser simplement euh le contenu du
message dans les programmes pour être
pour rester sur ce qu'on demande aux
enseignants de faire a évolué avec avec
la société donc pour résumer il est
normal que ce problème soit réinvesti
périodiquement il n'est pas je trouve sa
que de débat se repose sur la question
puisque ça intéresse tout le monde et
que nous si nous savons faire dans les
écoles peut-être faut-il revisiter ce
qu'on y fait justement du côté du Parti
socialiste alors quel est votre point de
vue en tout cas personnel sur la
question la morale laïque est-ce qu'il
faut la mettre en place est-ce que le
terme de morale laïque est bien choisi
et ça va servir à quoi tout à fait moi
je suis tout à fait favorable à la
l'enseignement de la morale laïque la
morale républicaine à une époque où pour
des tas de de raisons la la société peut
apparaître comme fragmenté cloisonné et
on met quoi dedans dans ben on y met les
grands principes de la vie de la vie en
commun du vivre ensemble justement la
laïcité le respect des choses qui
peuvent apparaître basiques mais qui
sont essentiel fondamental he le respect
d'autruie le respect de chaque chaque
conviction comment on vit en comment on
se comporte dans le dans le dans le
collectif dans le vivre ensemble son
rapport quand on est jeune aux
adultes à à l'autorité ça me semble être
des des notions et et une démarche tout
à fait intéressante une autre question
pour terminer un petit peu ce ce plateau
éducation vous allez déménager on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure dans le reportage
toujours lors de cette conférence de de
rentrée vous serez installé à Guill
encours dorénavant et le point important
c'est tout de même qu'il y a une partie
des services qui seront communs avec le
rectorat c'est ça c'est mutualisation
des moyens maintenant
oui non mais mutualisation des moyens
c'est toujours intéressant parce que
l'État est responsable donc il fait
attention à ce qu'il dépense mais en
l'occurrence nous sommes le département
siège de l'académie et en dehors des
locaux propres au département à la vie
départementale mais il y a aussi un
certain nombre de locaux pour la vie
académique donc on sachant que nous nous
devions trouver une autre location on a
uni ce problème à celui du rectorat qui
a plusieurs sites et simplement on aura
certains services du rectorat avec
inpection académique avenue du centre
donc à guuille en cours je viens de
passer devant et vous serez lo de ce
studio forcément Jean-Michel cagard je
vous propose de rester encore avec nous
durant les prochaines minutes puisqu'on
va accueillir des professeurs et des
élèves du lycée Blerot c'est à trappe et
vous verrez qu'ils ont décroché un prix
et vous allez voir dans quelques
instants de quoi il s'agit je remercie
en tout cas Jean-Philippe met d'être
venu sur ce plateau vous ferez votre
rentrée parlementaire le 11 septembre
entré chargé auparavant vous allez voir
que tout se vend sur Internet la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin a mis en vente mobilier
voitures ou encore bureau les
explications Joan sououdri envie de
changement pour la rentrée table bureau
ou encore voiture la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline a décidé de vendre aux enchères
quelques biens sur Internet on a des
postes on va dire de collaborateurs dans
différents taille 160 ou 180 on a des
plans de travail tout seul des plans de
travail complet avec des caissons on a
du mobilier de direction donc certaines
gammes selon les années à certains prix
comptez par exemple 600 € pour ce bureau
contre 50 ou 30 € pour d'autres modèles
parmi les 1880 produits proposés 4
véhicules de télévision magnétoscope et
même un four à pizza mis en vente 300 €.
tous s'achète sur internet mais seront
exposés ce samedi 8 septembre à Montini
le Bretonneux le public pourra ainsi
découvrir le mobilier en grandeur nature
à partir de là septembre constituera la
la 4e vague et on espère la dernière le
château de La Coudre ancien siège de
l'agglomération accueille actuellement
le mobilier à vendre il ouvrira ses
portes le 8 septembre pour présenter des
équipement en vente exclusivement sur
internet jusqu'au 16 septembre une fois
vidé le bâtiment devrait être transformé
en résidence pour personnes âgées